[Music]
- there we go one action hey guys
welcome back to off-the-record where we
talk about what biggest news get out of
the [ __ ] iPhone club piece which one
is that one
you [ __ ] loser do you stop the
wrapper on it I do because this one I'm
trying to keep it as nice as possible
you know it actually makes it worse if
you keep the plastic well I'm waiting
for the cake actually it does help why
does any case is gonna scratch it more
cuz then the dirt like all those little
dirt particles they get in there really
yeah then because it's moving it just
keeps scratching it I bet it's not gonna
scratch things in your pocket in a phone
dog I don't have that I usually keep it
I need that case all right [ __ ] I will
say though this is the best best
investment of my life man which which
phone is that no it's not Samsung Note 9
you like it yeah it's just a [ __ ]
beautiful phone man I love the screen
the colors I think the biggest thing
that I like about this though is the
fact that you could do multi apps did
you upload your very first picture on
Instagram yeah there might be no it's
not the pictures that are [ __ ] up the
things that look bad is gonna be in
story if you do it directly from the
camera so that's that's the thing that
the Android doesn't really support that
well yeah but everything else is
perfectly fine so the what do you mean
multi app like for example like you know
like if you're using your maps on your
phone like Maps has to take over the
whole screen and that's it Android you
could toggle it off to the corner and
continue to do what you want or split
screen monitors but on your phone
exactly so it [ __ ] makes sense I know
it's just the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen like I don't know why iPhone
can't do it I think it might be like
like a patent thing or something like
that like they won't they have like
ownership of it but I think that's like
the biggest reason why I switched over
so I can do multiple things at once
instead of happy to keep toggling out of
apps that's why they make laptops and
[ __ ] your phone is yeah but I'm not
carrying a laptop with me yeah I wanna
switch over and get what it was that
Android or something is good not bad
like wait do you have an iPhone you know
like when you get somebody somebody got
a green tag like oh yeah like it tells
you so much about that person already
but but it's also as being like weird
and like judgmental that stuff because
once you switch to the other phone you
don't see that anymore so like you don't
notice that but like we get it we're
like oh hey for me it's because it's
easy because all of my products is the
FL laptop to this and then we can all
airdrop and it's so simple there's also
like Google Drive Thru so I kind of had
it like I have Google Drive the way that
we did to do the only thing that I miss
about the Apple phone is airdrop that's
it just because I have everything Apple
yep you can't even use your [ __ ]
iPhone anymore I mean your what's it
called
I ever watch yeah oh yeah well you could
still use it you just you don't get all
that it's just a washing out but but I I
genuinely do believe though that this is
this is way better than you know you
sound like you drank the [ __ ]
kool-aid and now you're trying to have
us actually the app no it's not yes it
is people is telling you that just wants
you to fail okay
we're your friends gotta say to like
Apple is like cult stuff and I and I and
I know I'm in it the speakers are really
great on this and on top of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] headphone jack again I missed
the head is this sponsored I know I know
on this [ __ ] that is annoying
yeah you're trying to listen to [ __ ] and
charge your phone your pot yeah you
can't do it I don't like it
yeah the other thing that's pissing me
off is all these different [ __ ]
charges that they're coming out all your
Wireless now we just have like a thing
just charging wait Apple's charges
arises while I bought a while well so
yeah usually technology rolls out
quicker on Android it does or does but
it just looks dope er I don't think it
does no I genuinely don't think it does
like I mean I don't think they're either
yeah I don't anymore though like this is
[ __ ] beautiful with the colors
there's Steve Jobs past like they had
like nothing's changed so I'm that's why
I'm like when I when I
I always whenever I see David's stories
and should I always have to talk [ __ ]
first so I'm like you [ __ ] loser and
then I'm like let me know how it is I
might just jump jump ship - well one
thing I will give to Apple though like
they have something that's competitive
to their serie called Bixby Bixby sucks
dick like Bixby is terrible Bixby
doesn't [ __ ] you have to tell well I
have the Google thing - but big speed
controls like functions on the phone so
I'll be like ok big speed and it just
doesn't do [ __ ] I'll be like ok big
speed and then it'll say something and
I'll be like text if Tiffany she goes no
then I tried doing that this morning
could not understand a register who you
are so Bixby sucks ass but I never use
Siri anyway so they don't really matter
you know I know she can't use that Apple
watch you gotta get Google glass I just
want to see you walk in with like this
yeah I was watching a video on that the
other day because I wondered I was like
well this does seem a little futuristic
why didn't it take off because doesn't
it like give me this it gives you guys
the screen it was kind of bad well yeah
I was watching it well first of all yeah
it looks corneas book but then I saw
that you gotta like control it by
touching your tongue yeah and I'm like
so why don't I just have the phone yeah
like I want to be able to like control
with my eyes like let me do this [ __ ]
right here confirm I feel like if I got
who will get gas
Google glass like I would walk it and
this boy's just roundhouse me in the
face it does look like a [ __ ] me up pair
of laughs
like you would round ask me the face I
said to take it there sir we keep David
grounded there are certain items of
clothing that just says please Rob like
why I had those yeah like six pairs yeah
but those things are great for [ __ ]
training though okay that looks
intimidating if you foot swipe somebody
with that so uncommon it does not look
intimidating what's wipe in general is
it that is but then once you put the
shoe on and no one's but swiping that's
wearing those shoes you know you do the
pot you just pull on with your foot well
I would I don't I don't ever wear that
like casually or to a gym like it's
specifically if I'm doing a boy toy so
like if we're not doing it on mat I use
those fibers oh I'm sorry you do wear
those only Z okay so you do the web yeah
so I do that for a boy toy because if
we're not using mat I want to feel like
my toes and feet for when we kick and
stuff so you have to defend yourself
master Wong wears those desi yeah I said
got it from a form because that's kind
of I was trying to see if I should get a
box of shoes versus Vibrams and
everybody preferred the vibram suspense
but no girls like oh I wanna [ __ ] him no
girl set it either or without so
comments lately and you you're getting
that girl fanbase those women are so
shallow and I love them what do you
think they're like I can't believe you
talking [ __ ] about him I think he's so
dreamy and then they add up their
friends and stuff I'm like why what
what's going on here dude you don't give
a [ __ ] she knows I'm some [ __ ] the
most faithful human being on earth
aka she knows he got no game cuz I got
Muriel and I was fat at the time that's
true very sweet hmm and she's very
gullible no she's not yo so you make her
out to be a [ __ ] idiot she's not haha
she's very sweet I said he's at a
high-level position in her [ __ ]
company right now dude you know what's
so cool about Mary although if you guys
don't know anything about her I know
like putting her personal stuff out
there but prior to the job that she has
right now she was working in a
completely different field and so before
she did that she hated that job she quit
she decided to intern somewhere for free
she got a job there went to a couple of
conventions Network got her dropped into
animation which is what she wanted to is
she did it all within the span of less
than a year okay she's strong yeah
so like at the end of the day like I
always joke about her but you know if I
didn't respect the woman I would be with
her so yeah we know that yeah we all had
dinner and David makes her out to be
like this innocent as a girl she not
been doing a lot of party why are you
ere not all their dirty laundry yeah the
way y'all were describing her before
this I was picturing a girl always
wearing like a little flower crown like
white dress like oh that's what I'm
saying
she's one of us she's a scoundrel really
not really why we're on a different
level we are there certain off-limit
things but she's normal
this is normal girl yeah drinks from
Tanit on hangs out late at night way
past curfew past 10 o'clock curfew we're
so [ __ ] old Oh like I got so tired so
I got invited to this like Nike black
event you know like Kendrick and likes
is that everybody's supposed to be there
like [ __ ] a Jared Lorenzo everybody
right hit [ __ ] 11 o clock I train that
day house like I ain't goin [ __ ] knock
the [ __ ] out oh that's decision of my
life
mm-hmm do you like parties no if anyone
invites me to anything I'm like all the
time is everyone meeting and they're
like oh nine o'clock I'm like absolutely
not I go to bed at 9:30 I've been trying
to make myself I like to schedule yeah
dude I've been trying to because like I
feel like I need to like network more
and like meet more people but I'm like
and you know do you remember the like
that 12 midnight
do you guys ever do that I remember that
yeah that's when she starts pop it did
yeah but he'll be like a legend you know
you don't get to
club at 10:00 that's too [ __ ] early
you have dinner at 10:00 and then you go
at like midnight and you stay for like
an hour and you mean yeah yeah when I
used to like stream on Twitch I would
stay up until like 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning just eating hot cheetos playing
League of Legends but now I like going
to bed I like having a nice restful
sleep yeah same here
I don't have time for all this restful
sleep mom I gotta take a nap you still
not sleeping right no I'm like well
sleeping right to me is sleeping about
five hours so like if I get five I'm
pretty good but then like if it gets
like because I was sleep on average two
to three you got anxiety I used my mind
races a lot so I haven't thought my dad
has it too so his insomnia started going
is insomnia like [ __ ] started going away
when he was older cuz I was all this
[ __ ] so he's exhausted all the time but
prior to that I was sleeping an average
of like two to three oh and I was
sleeping power wake up sleep an hour
wake up sleep an hour wake up do you
sleep with the TV on
no now you just sleep and you wake up
just randomly I wake up and then my mind
Lurie racing so it's kind of annoying
but now knowing that Navy SEAL schedule
is it it's [ __ ] wild dude like so now
it's like if I do but if I stay active I
do my walks I'll sleep a solid five
hours oh that's a progress it's wait so
I'm not complaining five hours is way
better than our on two hours off to our
you know it's like it's weird I was
doing that for years do time you should
have been watching him breast feeding
tae Kuk I know I mean I'm already up
guys so we're good
I fell asleep at 8:00 last night and
then I woke up at midnight and then I
went back to sleep at 3:00 you stop that
oh yeah well I just after dinner I took
the dogs out and then I just like laid
on the bed and I knocked out til me at
the time changed and it's been getting
dark like around 4:30 5:00 I've been
sleepy like at 5:30 I'm like I want to
go to do I feel so good these days yeah
feels good yeah so he's not good these
days
you like channel by mama I feel like in
the winter we should be allowed to sleep
a little bit more like a little bit of
hibernation you know cuz it gets a
little dreary gots - its dreary I just
want to sleep all day you know it sucks
though about specifically SoCal I love
[ __ ] winter clothing like I love me -
oh that [ __ ] right
so more shopping and I was like cool I'm
gonna get this coat put it on in the
stores cold in the store right I put it
on I start sweating I'm like nah it's
not that cold though you know what's
crazy about this guy he has about 20
different jackets why I love Jack and
he's a hot ass person I probably have
like it's weird cuz I've never seen you
wear a jacket I know it doesn't get
[ __ ] cold without the idea not even
Japan like watch your legs shirtless
everyone was freezing I mean yeah shirt
off I mean not shirtless some checklist
I have a lot of jackets because I was
gonna wear a jacket not as hot as he is
right he's always complaining about no
he's pretty extreme but then I don't
wear my jackets either like only wear
like a handful he's hella hot so we went
to go [ __ ] uh we were working on a
barbell and in the morning gave this
dude a hug outside dude how are you
burning up already we need in a [ __ ]
start working out yeah dude like he's
just hot I wish I can lower jackets I
like this time of year though I used to
think I liked summer but then I'm
getting really good restful sleep
because of the cold air oh dude no when
it's cold in the morning I can't get up
really can't know if it's too cold like
I'll be under the blankets and I'll just
be trying to talk myself up into getting
out I had to get I have like a space
heater I had to get a remote for it plug
that [ __ ] in so like I wake up and I do
my like you know check my social media
and [ __ ] we turn on the heater wait for
the warmth you know what I used to do
inside to methods when I would put a
school and I had to wake up [ __ ]
early to go to school and it's so cold
yeah and it's so cold I would have my
clothes I would pick up my clothes the
night before have it on the bed like
laying there so then when I'd wake up
I'd put my clothes underneath I did that
do that the clothes is warm cuz when
it's really cold the clothes go Barney
yeah you get all wrinkled and stuff no
no I like there's a method to put it on
and then the other method was I would
get a blow dryer and then I would like I
would like make everything warm and then
my body warm as I got a genius when I
first started do that I'm like that's
pretty genius but I'm very wrinkly
that's why I sleep with a dog
oh that's just but they want about all
the dog hair how do you get out of I
wake up and then I'm warm and then I get
up why don't do that what jobs
I keep because she doesn't want to wake
up early or I don't want to wake up
early sometimes it depends so like on
the weekends we sleep together but then
like today like I get up super early and
she does ah that's go to sleep late or
like if I sleep like yesterday at 3 a.m.
and then wake up at like 7:00 or
whatever right like that's I wish I
could just like I don't mind maybe the
in sleep but the fact that I can't sleep
late at night I would just like it if I
could just wake up later but I can't
like but what's your natural waking up
time natural is around 9 a.m. oh no
matter what without that's your natural
yeah so even if you sleep at like 7
you're probably know about nine or it'd
be like nine thirty nine forty men you
know what I mean but it won't go past
that
I hardly ever unless I'm like super
exhausted so it's just like I have to
make sure I gotta sleep because if I
don't I'm still gonna wake up around 9
or 10 a.m. so then I'm just like a
zombie for the rest of the day so say
you ever tried taking a hot bath oh I
always take a shower before I go to
sleep like a hot shower shower before
bed yep I have two guys think dude do
you you looked at me like what yeah wait
yeah I do it before and after for and
afters I do a morning shower like I do
morning shower too yeah oh you do both
well I have so if I'm not clean I don't
sleep that well yeah and then ISKCON and
in the morning when I'm not like clean I
don't feel like I'm ready to take the
day on yeah I took a shower this morning
me too yeah the nighttime shower people
I mean I get that too always because so
you don't work out everyday right I
don't work out every because I used to
not shower like at night or whatever
because I didn't feel gross I'll be
chilling at house in the house all day
and if I would in sweat if you sweat a
lot if you
like [ __ ] yes your whole body's like
just [ __ ] do I mean sticky
I actually feel nasty after four hours
if I if I had the time and I really
wanted to shower to comfort like back in
the day I would like when I was in high
school and I had all the time in the
world I would shower in the morning and
then I'll go to school come back and
then shower and there's people hey you
want to go watch some movies I'm gonna
cool a shower go out to go watch movies
came back home in a shower again
no it took like four showers out because
I just feel so greasy like a
[ __ ] yeah I don't know I'm never
well you guys exercise everyday if I
break out a sweat I must have been in
danger why I cannot get myself to
exercise I can't do it like for a while
I was an MD 30-day squat challenge I did
that [ __ ] though and lifetime yeah deal
my butt was looking back it was nice I
was like I want this every day but I
don't wanna work for it so you know yeah
I can't I don't work out every day keep
it this is just hard man I do it for
mental health yeah like it's so
important that you have to have your
mind and your body like aligned and you
can't do that unless you work out and
like I want to so bad you know I like
like like I don't even work out anymore
cuz it's just hard to do something that
feels like a chore but if you find a fun
game I download it just dance I I did it
the first day I had so much fun it was
so good there's a lot of things that
people don't think about in terms of
like how like your physical well-being
affects you mentally like it's true oh
yeah it's kind of crazy like like your
self-esteem your calm I'm less neurotic
when I am working out like Jake time
like specifically that's not just like
pseudoscience though like that's like
legit there are statistics there's
things that show exactly how your
personal health affects your mental and
cardiovascular just like exercises
releases was it dopamine or serotonin
one of those happy medicines but it's a
natural antidepressant because you are
working on a barbell for that time yeah
for six months I
really I felt great and I would wake up
like nothing in the mornings and I came
over to your is please and like I was
just like I was living life like a
normal person
and then now I feel all cloudy and like
yeah it's just it's I think it's very
natural for us as animals and creatures
to stay active to a certain extent right
up getting a certain amount of sunlight
like there are friends that I know right
now that they've always worked like
[ __ ] night shifts and they always
sleep in the daytime and they just look
they look great like they look odd you
know any mean I'm like what the [ __ ]
like how do you look like thirty years
old or what the [ __ ] happened is like oh
I'm working night shifts now you know oh
yeah there's like the study that people
who work night shifts I forgot they died
earlier they died way they get a hot
problem yeah it's pretty crazy though
men like just like it's just even
something small like this there's some
people who have like depression issues
right like their studies that be showing
activity moving around helps them with
that [ __ ] and JK water to be fair if if
working out will help me with my
depression but like how am I supposed to
overcome the depression to start working
out yeah I think I think it's the the
the pressure of committing to something
so big right and then like I always say
like baby steps like walk around the
block first just move your body first
and it turns into a domino effect the
problem with the idea of working out is
it's stressful and it's hard it doesn't
have to be there though it could work
you could work up to that so like when
you first start its just walk around the
block just move your body because people
aren't used to just moving like go to
the mall move like go to the beach and
walk with your friends do fun activities
right and then when your blood starts
flowing then you can go to the next
level in the next level like go go do a
volleyball game with all your friends or
something oh you guys work out all the
time I'm a shy no I'm with you I mean
literally in the same way working outs
very bad my book comes walking dude well
my mom where he worked up to that
to this chair I had to walk from my uber
to right here right that counts
I feel like there's like a minimum
requirements checklist and I check it
all off I check off every single box I
breathe
that's cardio no I've run my mouth
everything is fine everything is baby
steps like even with like like the Muay
Thai and stuff that I was doing I did
once a week I did once a week for like
maybe like two two months two and a half
months three months and then I worked up
to two times a week and then it was ten
I was three times so I mean you started
with walking what thirty minutes or
something like that in the morning
what was it I just walked it was like a
mile then I'm with the two miles than
three miles so I swap and I didn't do
anything else besides walk that's all I
did
there's walk put a podcast on or I
[ __ ] listen to music walk came back
home Wow came back home and then that
slowly became three that like three days
out the week and then I just seven days
out the week I've got three days out
like three miles and then it became
seven days a week so I just had to do
something consistently every day so
every day I could walk cuz I mean it
doesn't require anything you don't get
sore from it you don't even like nothing
happens I think that's the thing as
people go too hard too fast and then
they get scared cuz sure doctor one time
I was asking about my physical health
like they were doing a whole bunch of
different things and I remember I got
the paper back and he had different
checkboxes for like workout thing or
whatever and he had checked off
sedentary lifestyle for me which is most
people most people at 90% of us worried
I told you I'll walk at least like three
times a week
look at that sedentary yeah I guess so
sedentary lifestyle my human isn't that
what rocks are know you've been unless
you're a blue-collar worker you're a
sedentary lifestyle even if you train an
hour a day five days a week it's still
said until you all still kind of
sedentary yeah
[Music]